millions of Americans remain subjected
to unprecedented restrictions on their
personal lives their daily lives their
families lives the corner of iris lock
downs continue in many places you may
not know that because it gets no
publicity but it's true and if you're
living under it you definitely know as a
result of this tens of millions of
people are now unemployed a huge number
of them have no prospects of working
again many thousands of small businesses
are closed and will never reopen more
Americans have become dependent on drugs
and alcohol seen their marriages
dissolve become clinically depressed
some of them delayed their weddings
others were banned by the government
from burying their loved ones in
funerals some Americans will die of
cancer because they couldn't get cancer
screenings some unknown number have
taken their own lives in despair others
have flooded the streets to riot because
bottled up rage and frustration take
many forms the cost of shutting down the
United States and denying our citizens
desperately needed contact with one
another it's hard to calculate but the
cost has been staggering the people
responsible for doing all of this say
they have no regrets about it we faced a
global calamity they say kovat 19 was
the worst pandemic since the Spanish flu
that flu killed 50 million people we had
no choice we did the right thing that's
what they're telling us is it true the
answer to that question matters not just
because the truth always matters
but because the credibility of our
leaders is at stake here this is the
biggest decision they have made in our
lifetimes they were able to make it they
rule because we let them their power
comes from us so the question now and
always is are they worthy of that power
that's not a conversation they want to
have and right now they don't have to
have that conversation because right now
all of us are distracted and mesmerized
by the woke revolution underway outside
they created a separate country in
Seattle huh and as we said we'll bring
you the latest on that in just a minute
but we do think it's worth for a minute
taking a pause to assess whether or not
they were in fact lying to us about the
corona virus and our response to it and
the short answer is this yes they were
definitely lying as a matter of public
we can say conclusively the lockdowns
were not necessary in fact we can prove
that and here's the most powerful
evidence states that never lock down at
all states where people were allowed to
live like Americans and not cower
indoors alone in the end turned out no
worse than states that had mandatory
quarantines the state you probably live
in the states that did lockdown at first
but were quick to reopen have not seen
explosions of coronavirus cases all of
this is the opposite of what they said
would happen with great confidence the
media predicted mass death at places
like Lake of the Ozarks in Ocean City
Maryland places where the middle class
dares to vacation but those deaths never
happened in the end the Wuhan
coronavirus turned out to be a dangerous
disease but a manageable disease like so
many others far more dangerous with the
lockdowns themselves for example in New
York Pennsylvania New Jersey
Massachusetts panicked and incompetent
governors forced nursing homes to accept
infected coronavirus patients and as a
result many thousands died and they died
needlessly this is all a remarkable
story but it's going almost entirely
uncovered the media would rather tell
you why you need to hate your neighbor
for the color of his skin the media
definitely don't want to revisit what
they were saying just a few weeks ago
when they were acting as press agents
for power drunk Democratic politicians
back then news anchors were ordering you
to stop asking questions and obey all
right so while most Americans are
staying inside or should be right if
they're not out protesting like fools
they're not happy about being told to
stay home staying home saves lives and
the rest of us should be staying at home
for our mothers and the people that we
love and to keep us farther apart will
ultimately bring us closer together in
this cause our collective conscientious
actions staying home oh if you love your
mother you will do what I say
turns out cable news anchors don't make
very subtle propagandists and then
Memorial Day arrived in May and some
states started to reopen millions of
grateful Americans headed out doors for
the first time in months and the media
attack
them for doing that called them killers
swimming with your kids they told us was
tantamount to mass murder jam-packed
pool parties at the lake of the ozarks
resort in other places over the holiday
weekend if you if any people were
wearing masks or practicing social
distancing hardly packed into
overcrowded pools despite the ongoing
pandemic let's face it the weirdness of
being that bunched up in what looks like
a kind of human stool frankly a lot of
the people in those crowds they thought
they were you know standing up for what
the president believes in and that is
not to care about the public safety part
of this look at this I mean this is kind
of crazy considering we're in the middle
of a global pandemic I mean there's one
person equipped you know that that's
that's curving the curve that's not
flattening it a massive crowd of people
crammed together as if it were just an
ordinary holiday weekend despite the
risks of a virus that has killed more
than ninety eight thousand people boy
that montage was the opposite of a Mensa
meeting has that much dumbness been
captured on tape ever the last clip you
saw was from May 25th that was just over
two weeks ago ninety-eight thousand
people are dead how dare you leave your
house you don't work in the media
you're not essential but it didn't take
long for that message to change
completely in fact it took precisely
five days here's the same braid
brain-dead news anchor you just saw less
than a week later he's no longer angry
you'll notice about Americans going
outside as long as they are rioting and
burning and not doing something sinful
like chilling with their children he's
delighted by it and let's not forget if
anyone is judging this I'm not judging
this I'm just wondering what is going on
because we were supposed to figure out
this experiment a long time ago our
country was started because this is how
the Boston Tea Party rioting
so don't do not get it twisted and think
that oh this is some something that has
not never happened before and then this
is so terrible and where are we and
these savages and all of that this is
how this country was started yeah don't
judge this is how this country was
started by looting CBS and setting fire
to Wendy's of course you took American
history
you knew that Andrew Cuomo's brother
must have been in the same history class
because he had the same reaction
America's major cities are filled with
people demanding this country become
more fair more just and please show me
where it says that protests are supposed
to be polite and peaceful because I can
show you that outraged citizens are the
ones who have made America what she is
and led to any major milestones they're
here to yell criticize blame and shame
citizens have no duty to check their
outrage Wow so one minute they were mass
murderers for going outside now their
Sam Adams they're Patriots they're
American heroes if all of this seems
like a pretty abrupt pivot fret not
rioting is not a health risk as long as
it helps the Democratic Party's
prospects in the November election
rioting will not spread the krona virus
sounds implausible but we can be certain
of that because last week hundreds of
self-described public health officials
signed a letter saying so they announced
that the black lives matter riots are a
vital contribution to public health in
effect they're an essential medical
procedure but that doesn't mean you get
to go outside you don't
thanks to coronavirus you do not have
the right to resume your life and if you
complain about that it's quote white
nationalism that was their professional
conclusion does a single American
believe any of that no of course not it
is too stupid even for CNN to repeat so
they mostly ignored it that's an ominous
sign if you think about it it means
these people are done trying to convince
you even to fool you they're not making
arguments they're issuing decrees they
think they can they no longer believe
they need your consent to make big
decisions too
the country once the authorities stop
trying to change your mind even by
deceit it means they've decided to use
force and they have during the lockdowns
people whose loved ones died were not
allowed to have funerals for them think
about that it's hard to think of
anything crueler but it happened to a
lot of people they claimed it was
necessary it was not necessary and we
know that because now that a man has
died whose death is politically useful
to the Democratic Party the authorities
have given him three funerals and not a
word about a health risk or consider
King County Washington
that's for Seattle is restaurants in
King County are operating at just twenty
five percent capacity that's the law now
non-essential businesses are allowed
just 15% capacity the effect of that is
economic disaster most small businesses
run on very small margins they can't
survive for long and in fact many have
failed what should they do they should
join a Tifa obviously because in King
County Washington and Tifa can do
whatever antiva wants to do site they've
taken over an entire six block section
of downtown Seattle and that's fine with
health authorities there no social
distancing required they're essential
you getting the pictures is adding up to
a message yes the message is you were
plate we were all plate corrupt
politicians scared us into giving up
control over the most basic questions in
our own lives at the same time they gave
more power to their obedient followers
like in Tifa while keeping the rest of
us trapped at home and censored online
in other words they used a public health
emergency to subvert democracy and
install themselves as monarchs how are
they able to do this the sad truth is
they did it because we let them do it we
believed them
therefore we obeyed them if there's
anything good to come out of this
disaster it's that none of us will ever
make that mistake again